hey it's evan and today i'm doing
another one of my Fiverr gigs where i'm
helping out a fellow entrepreneur giving
them some feedback on their website
today I have I bizcard who's got a
website ID card workshop com so if I pop
it up here I look at ID card workshop
the first thing that hits me is well I
kind of get a sense of what they're all
about they're making these ID cards but
there's a lot of content on this side
this is this is hard to it's hard on the
eye and I guess it looks like they're
trying to pound in as much information
as possible you don't want people to
miss anything but when you do that it's
so overwhelming that you're not quite
sure where to look so if I'm trying to
figure out what this company does I'm
sure it tells me here let's read a
little bit professional easy-to-use
membership management an ID card
software for business and organizations
okay with this built-in okay look this
is a long sentence with its built-in
powerful multi-layer ID card designer
various templates and samples ID card
workshop enables you to create ID cards
employee badges membership cards loyalty
cards VP cars or any type of ID cards
never never been easier so we have a
grammatical error in there but these
long sentences people do not want to
read it this looks like it could be cool
so if your business who has to manage
the ID of the people coming in your
employees or VIP cards at a club or
whatever it is I don't know how people
go about creating them this is looks
like a pretty cool software solution to
help you out for the people who own this
website to make it easier you need to
simplify this I love you know this is a
great picture that shows what you do a
little bit but this text is out of
control people are not going to read all
of this stuff so you want to simplify it
come up with two three main things that
you can do and how it helps and make
that easy to understand I like that you
have some screenshot so I can kind of
look at what your software can do let's
click on one card design so I could put
in their picture name all that
information the software actually looks
easy to use a software is easier to look
at than the website right nice buttons
clearly defined
super easy I get a better sense of what
you're doing by looking at the screen
shots then reading this website full of
text so something to think about you
guys have some skills to make this just
apply your software skills over to your
website some partners you know I don't
know any of these names but maybe that
means something to some people it's
great do you have some you know some
press it's great to see Yahoo Boston com
we've got a little bit of some publicity
there so that's great my next step here
would be the two down little purchase so
it's great let's see how much the same
cause so looks like i have two options
here 30-day license for fifteen bucks a
month or single unlimited license for
180 bucks total I don't know what this
kind of stuff costs but it doesn't seem
to me like that's crazy unreasonable for
people who really need to have ID cards
in their businesses for whatever reason
to be able to get away with it at 180
bucks doesn't seem like it's too crazy
considering all the stuff you go through
here I think the biggest challenge here
for the the business owner is to make
this easier to understand so when people
come here they quickly get a sense of
what you're all about and want to make a
decision to buy I'd love to see a little
bit more about who's behind this company
so you know why did you start this
what's your background who are the
people again people like to buy from
people so share your story show your
smiling face tell me why you started
this business why it's important to you
if you can get people to read that then
they're more likely to want to buy from
you instead of going to some other
company so something about about the
business maybe I'm missing it maybe
there's something at the bottom no
nothing here press room so it means
great you're getting some press but
again i'd love to see some more
information about you guys whoever the
founder is here take a picture make a
video if you're up for it and go from
there be great to see that information
so but overall number one most important
thing clean this up make it look like
your software make it as easy to use as
your software and you get more people
buying thanks for the review our if you
guys like this video give it a thumbs up
below and I'd love to hear what you have
to think about this website or if you
have a question about your business
leaving a comments below and I'll make a
video reply thank you so much
much and I'll see you soon